not just job Cuts Elon Musk eliminated
Twitter days of rest and work from home
policies last week pushing a 24 7 work
culture if you're a Twitter employee who
has a satisfying work balance life
work-life balance you may not want to
hear what the new boss has to say musk
cut close to 3 700 jobs at Twitter or
half of the workforce via email last
week musk has also removed Twitter's
days of rest monthly days off for
employees to rest and recharge and it's
pushed to implement 24 7 word culture
additionally Bloomberg reported that
musk plans to end the company's remote
work policy and ask remaining employees
to work to return to office full-time
fantastic now watch this next one here
after weeks of media teeth
Nation over musk takeover Twitter sees
explosive user engagement Twitter's
daily user growth hit an all-time high
during the first full week of Elon Musk
owning the platform according to a
company document obtain by The Verge
since musk's dramatic takeover Twitter's
monetizable daily user growth has
accelerated more than 20 percent while
Twitter's largest market the US has
grown even more quickly per the FAQ
Twitter has added more than 15 million
more than 15 million monetizable daily
user not Bots crossing the court of a
billion marks since the end of second
quarter when it stopped reporting
financials as public as a public company
so on one end they're bashing the guy on
the other end it's getting more
engagement than ever before look the
fact that he is just doing this blue
thing for eight bucks it's like look how
many people are doing it I don't know
what the numbers are on that yet but
people wanted to give Twitter money and
Twitter had no mechanism to do it I
think Twitter is going to look
completely 180 different in a year from
now than it looks right now it's going
to look much more like WeChat which is a
Chinese app which there's all sorts of
reasons that we shouldn't be cloning
Chinese apps but that you're going to be
able to do much more within Twitter in
terms of purchases and communities and
all sorts of stuff that's obviously the
route that he's going but he has
unlocked something he has unlocked the
fact that the government was in on it
with the previous guys and Jack Dorsey
should be hauled in front of Congress
again and again I know nothing ever
comes of it when they do it of course
but Jack Dorsey has a lot to pay for
they still have to expose what really
happened with the laptop and who fully
decided all of this stuff and was was a
call put in by the government to Vijaya
got a who is the head of trust and
safety and they there's so much that he
can expose right now and covet and all
hence why Joe Biden is up there going
we'll we'll find out and also don't
think don't forget one thing with with
the eight dollars and how he's trying to
monetize he's realizing he can't just
rely on corporate advertisers yeah to
continue you know operating how they
have been because how many advertisers
have already pulled out of Twitter No
someone like 50 has this is definitely
your guys Department more than mine but
has anyone ever bought a company at the
premium that he bought a company at and
then within two weeks fired 75 of the
workforce like is that is there any
comparable to that anywhere past that
normal
it happens all the time with smaller
companies but not at bigger companies
some would you agree with that not at
this time buying buying something at a
premium and then doing something like
this that's not usually the way it works
the way it works is you know it's 1995
and you buy Harley Davidson when it's
really having a tough run but it's a
beautiful brand and it's got products
that can be revived then you remove half
of the people and you restructure it and
then you take off again because it's
Harley Davidson that happened to
Harley-Davidson a couple times in cycle
but it's never a premium where you pay
like this this huge premium for it and
say okay I'm gonna do this now sometimes
you know private Equity will buy
companies like this and then what
they'll do is they'll see they went in
and it's a good sector with good growth
and great fundamentals of the company
and they believe that that you know a
seven percent five percent layoff is
going to increase the profitability of
the company because they believe they're
going to run it a little bit better than
the the previous administration did but
I've never seen something that this
level of Premium that's your first level
of departure regarding that so like if
you're using the Harley David example I
assume that they're firing because they
want to restructure and just kind of
like reposition the workforce
yeah I'm saying this company's not doing
well for a reason and I'm about to fix
it exactly meaning it's not ideological
at all it's actual business but I guess
first impression would be musk is firing
these people a lot of it is because
ideological reasons right I mean is that
that's the premise that I would kind of
obviously there's restructuring and
reformatting in business but is some of
this ideological reasons like we saw
what percentage of Silicon Valley and
those types of companies donate to D's
versus ours I'm wondering how much of
this restructuring firing all that is
business versus ideological I would say
yes but no yes there is ideological
elements here but the other side of it
he's buying this because he thinks he
can do something with it you know let's
not forget this is not George Soros
buying a company and doing it this is an
operator an entrepreneur oh you're going
to make rockets go to Mars well he's
almost there you know uh oh oh you're
you're going to do the same with the
electric car he's got Battery Technology
he's got electric cars that look good
that run good they're reliable I mean
he's pulling it off so is he making
changes that have ideological elements
to it sure but I think he looks inside
and says wow there needs to be free
speech it needs to be this this needs to
be so much better and I can make a buck
on it and these sons of [ __ ] aren't
doing it so I'm gonna get I'm gonna make
a wholesale change but I think at the
core
some people see ideological you know you
know wholesale layoffs on that no I
think he's looking you Knuckleheads are
doing a bad job you're doing a really
bad job and I'm gonna buy this I'm gonna
do a better job I think I think a couple
times not to cut you off I think a
couple of times like people came in like
and they're like coming in he's like did
you ever talk [ __ ] about me and they're
like no they just pulled up their tweet
yeah you're out that's what I'm saying
like you probably you're probably right
about me you're out okay number 67 out
68.
but also also try to imagine what so
many of these employees were doing on
the DL like now that now that we have
some insight and this is what he really
has to expose if he wants to clean it up
and then and then move the company
forward it's like how many of those
employees were reading your DMs because
there's no doubt that they were 100
there's just no doubt that they were how
many of them were making sure that for
example in July of 2021 when I tweeted
out that mandates were coming and
vaccines weren't working and I got
suspended on Twitter was that either the
government that did it or was it an
Insider a Twitter that did it he can now
figure this all out they have logs of
all of this stuff this is not you know
they can't paper shred all of this so
it's like if he just goes in and figures
out who did what when did they do it and
get rid of everybody I mean everybody
there do not hire because of equity
higher because of Competency and and
give everybody what they want it's it's
all he has it in some ways it's a very
easy job because everyone wants him to
succeed except except for like what you
said there don't do not hire because of
equity higher because of Competency and
that's a major theme in America today
right it's very bizarre I don't hire
people based on the color of their skin
I like what he said uh yesterday he says
please note that Twitter will do lots of
dumb things in coming months we will
keep that what works and change what
doesn't so he's testing right yeah
here's what we're trying what do you
think about this what do you think about
that what do you think about this what
do you think about that and people are
uh adjusting to it and he's going to
constantly figure out a way to make it
better Dorsey yesterday uh apologize did
you see the doors apology yesterday
Dorsey did you read the dorsey's apology
it rings very Hollow to me you when you
had a chance dude you did everything
wrong then you step away also The Dorsey
thing and I've chatted with him
privately a couple times the The Dorsey
thing seems very odd to me because you
guys all know how hard it is to run one
company so now you're running Twitter
like the most public company in the
history of the world where everything is
happening and he was also running what
was the other company he was the CEO of
Stripes
how is that even possible and then and
then you know he goes in front of
Congress and he lies at you shadow man
no and it's like come on man but they
know that nothing ever happens with
these things so you know he's just
trying to get back in I don't blame him
for what he's doing he's trying to
figure out a way to wiggle himself back
in and that that's what any of us would
do right you know if you did everything
wrong all the way well Dorsey must look
at Elon after you know dorsey's running
two companies look at Elon he's running
Tesla and SpaceX and neural link and uh
supports the satellite company
starlink and now it's Tesla it's like
this guy might be an alien he's an alien
at him
I like what he's doing I like what he's
doing Dave did you see about a week and
a half ago where he actually he actually
uh tweeted uh two images from emails
between the two Executives oh yeah yeah
and so he's putting it out there so it's
like okay
I'll tell you what for all you guys want
to be yelling about this
here
because he walked in and he said you
know what can you pull the executive
emails here and here for the guys that
just let go don't touch them just pull
them out there I want to see this
dialogue oh this is very interesting and
so he showed America he showed us this
and I think that's uh that's a sign of
what he's saying it is also kind of
funny that a guy who's literally sending
us to Mars decides to get into this
fight of all fights which is the most
painstaking you know just the craziest
cultural fight you could possibly ever
get in and then he fires these guys and
now you know the lawsuits are going to
be endless right because he's trying to
stop their golden parachutes because
he's firing them for incompetency
they're going to obviously claim that
they were not like he's just opened
himself up to everything this guy who
could literally leave Earth have no
problem that any of us could ever
imagine he loves it yeah he loves it
what do you think is his actual
motivation because prior to Twitter
I don't think he was a big First
Amendment Free Speech got like that was
in his fight whatsoever it was you know
Star Trek Vibes Third Dimension another
world let's go to space all that now
what do you think is motivation I don't
think that it wasn't his mo pre covet I
just think it wasn't as bizarre as a god
during nobody was like what the hell is
going on here and he says look I'm gonna
buy one of these companies you know I'm
gonna buy a Twitter you know of course
we'd love for him to buy Facebook and
some of these other guys I don't think
he can go raise that kind of money yet
uh in the valley unless if the valuation
goes lower but I think he has one other
play he's got to do I really think he's
got one other play he's got a major
newspaper and he's got to finalize CNN
six billion dollars okay go buy cnn6p
scare the [ __ ] out of everybody there if
he pass on now what happens is now he
owns one of the virtual governments
which is Twitter and if he goes buys one
of the mainstream the ultimate
mainstream fake news you know he buys
CNN do you realize this is the one way
to actually get these people to go to
Canada this would be the ultimate way to
get people to say you know what I'm
finally doing it I'm leaving so with all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bad toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]